how are you check
we are recording here
and camera going
and going
excelente and that means excellent
in spanish you know that's a that's one
of the easy ones
there's harder ones pele grosso
and that means danger
in spanish so it gets trickier
you know the closer you get to spain
really
um you know i made a mistake i saw
a man the other day and he was in a um
[Music]
in a he had a hat on right
you know he had that brim and so i went
up and it said
mariners you know and so i said oh you
know
are you a big fan you know i said
unfortunately you guys are one of the
only teams never to win the
the pennant you know the championship
the major league championship
and he's just look he said excuse me i
said
you know we're you guys are one of the
you know seattle you guys are one of the
only teams
you know to never win it it's
unfortunate
and he's just you know i said you know i
was a saints fan and they
they had they didn't win it for 30 years
and
you know i know your pain a little and i
said you know
and he's just kind of looking at me when
i say you know i love itchy row
and i always have really you know
enjoyed ichiro suzuki if you
if you've seen him or if you haven't he
is a man
and i'm not gonna you know racially
profile him but
you know he could be bobby lee's daddy
i'll say that
you know you wouldn't be surprised if
you looked up the sung sang dynasty and
he was in
one of the arts you know one of the
drawings or whatever but um
you know i said i love dichyro you know
tino martinez i'm rattling off different
mariners players
and he's like what are ex what are you
and at this point i can tell he's
getting a little upset and i started to
think something was wrong i started to
feel high honestly
and he's like what in the [ __ ] are you
talking about
i said the mariners and i pointed his
hat and it said
marines on it
and uh
i mean just damn you know just
nothing there's something when you ask a
member of an armed force
you know when you ask a man who is a you
know a warrior
who's traveled other lands you know to
you know to fight and you know try and
you know hook up with women on his off
days and
you know or be secretly in love with men
or whatever
you know a military when you ask a man
like that and you just repeatedly kind
of accuse him of being a
seattle mariners fan it's
well it's not something you want to do
let's crack into a tune or two
[Music]
that one ah let's try a different one
here
these are summertime melodies you know
beets
here we go
[Music]
and this has that little summertime vibe
kind of
maybe you and your lady taking a walk by
the lake
or by a drainage canal or something you
[Music]
know
you and your lady splitting a piece of
nicorette out there
you look out and you see something in
the water
[Music]
there you go and that's beautiful right
there that's embrace me summertime
by isobel walton
and that is supposed to be a damn
summertime kind of tune
melody you know something to just
you know just give years a little bit of
halloween you know just something's
you know to somebody you know
my mother used to have a friend that
would come over sometime and
i don't know if he was a friend as much
as he was just somebody that
was trying to you know have sex with my
mother
and he used to do this little thing he'd
put a tic tac in his ear
and then turn his head and make it go in
there
and you know i don't know
i mean i honestly have no idea if it
ever if the man ever really got it out
or not
but shout out the uh marines and the
seattle mariners
and do not make that mistake
here's one
[Music]
oh yeah now this is that country time
lemonade kind of
uh
[Music]
oh yeah this is definitely a couple
white guys maybe split a piece of uh
you know viagra or blue chew gum you
know
that weiner gum
and they're both now it's a threesome
they're both banging in
you know just hammering into a young
woman they've both known for a long time
a woman who is willing to be in this you
know she's enjoying it and
[Music]
everybody's doing good
there they go
a couple youngsters getting that sex in
baby doing a little bit of [ __ ] right
there
[Music]
okay and that's some good music right
there
uh it is july 27th
and it is the year 2-0-2-0
in case the aliens have heard you know
have lumbered upon this
you know in case the the vessel that is
current society ends up in the
you know if the realm closes and
everything ends
and the vessel that we are on just
titanics
into into the past
and one day an alien you know some
little sneaky ass alien
because you know some of them are
you know he's probably doing a little
bit of space coke or something
busting a gram a damn you know
moonketamine or something
and he lumbers over and cracks open the
time capsule
that was 20 20.
maybe this will fall right right out
onto them
you know maybe uh ken griffey jr
will join the marines um
what's happening man uh i've been
what have i been doing i helped somebody
move today
and that [ __ ] will get you
you know there's a thing a service
called taskrabbit you put in something
you want on there
you want somebody to do something and
they'll see if they'll do it
you know oh hank will do it for forty
dollars you put whatever
get me a dessert you know or you know
stand in line at the dmv
you know [ __ ] tickle my cousin do
whatever
do something you know you get that
subordinate it's somebody that'll
come they'll do it you know it's
anything called taskrabbit
it's an app it's an application on your
iphone you get that sucker
and you say look you know i want i want
a man to
you know fill his mouth with lump crab
meat and run around a damn
uh you know indoor
track all right
you know reginald he'll do it for forty
dollars man
and it's just you can get anything i
want somebody i mean
i think it's nothing sexual you can't
get but you could get anything else
i want somebody to come over here and
hug me you know seven eight dollars
just different options man they got a
lot of options on there um
so i used that taskrabbit found a man to
help and next thing you know i got a
nice new lamp
dropped a sofa off by my friend's house
she decided she didn't want it after we
moved her sofa out
so then we had to go back me and this
taskrabbit this man named andrew
and he was tall this man probably damn
i mean i'd be crazy to say nine feet but
i'd be
dishonest if i said he was anything
under eight one
this 8-1 fella i mean this guy probably
had a wiener on him like a damn
you know he had a wiener that i bet
would eat a worm if you fed it to it
that kind of guy you know just a real he
got that olympic wiener
you know you put his wiener you know
behind something it'll jump over it
that kind of when you got that much body
and that might you know eight
one your dick will do a stunt
yo dick'll do a stunt
and that's really there's nothing wrong
with that
um yeah so i helped some moving
uh oh they had a rally not far from my
place today
a protest and um
pretty cool to see you know i mean i'm
all about people
actively expressing their you know their
disdain and their discomfort
you know people just putting their voice
out in there and creating a fire with
their throats
and with their emotions
um i mean at some points it gets wild
too i mean a lot of these
protests have turned into just photo
opportunities
you know little dorothy's out there
showing her you know
showing her coochie do a damn
[Music]
you know to a fireman
and they take a picture and say oh
dorothy's you know she's gonna save
antarctica and you're like uh
don't know you know dorothy's gonna get
some damn
probably some creosote in her cr in her
crea crotch man she's getting
you know she's gonna end up with some
damn you know a second-hand disease i
mean it's just dangerous
you know you open your vagina up down on
a damn busy intersection
you know [ __ ] gets dangerous it's just a
lot of people out there now just looking
for photo opportunities i find
you know what what's the best angle how
can i get this thing that makes me look
great
and makes police or makes
firemen or even anybody look bad
i saw one person look like they had a
fake fireman out there with them you
know
and they were not tickling them but kind
of trying to look like they were getting
in a fight or somebody really just
looked like somebody was just kind of
tickling a fat cop
which that's something they should do
every now and then get the fattest cop
out and let everybody tickle him a
little
i'm not saying that will calm or quell
the the
some of the anarchy but i think it'll
it will put a it'll help a little
you know if you saw a bunch of real dark
hands tickling a fat cop that's gonna
that's gonna set everybody a little bit
at ease i think
but um
yeah what did i saw something where some
antifa
members you know someone had put on
their job application that they served
two years in antifa
and that they were in two battles like
freaking battles
it was like yeah you know i you know i
served under the
under the watch of milkshake 47.
as we commandeered a dsw shoes
you know you may know me from some of my
work uh
you know there's a snapchat video of me
uh
beating a small business owner you know
like i don't think you put that on your
job application
oh yeah you may know me um i was i
you know i wasn't oh i i served in
antifa
for for for two weeks um
you know i uh i started a fire
uh outside of an abandoned toys r us
so you know there's definitely some
snapchats of my work
just like what the f what the f's
what the f's um what else man what else
is going on things are going on
it's summertime
[Music]
it's a time for love i do know that
yeah watch a little bit of baseball what
else i you know i didn't do too much
went for a couple runs um
you know i'm gonna go to nashville uh
next weekend i believe you know and go
be around there for about a week
just to kind of see what's cracking you
know see what's going on and get a vibe
um waiting to hear back on the animated
cartoon you know we
we took a a pitch out like pitching out
to
networks for the um
the saturday morning tunes you know that
are on
instagram and so we finally got a good
package to take out a real cartoon
we've been taking it out and and i've
been getting some response from a couple
spots so
uh i'll keep you guys posted on how
that's going but thank you so much
over time for just supporting uh
the cartoons and just the ability to be
able to do that
you know um that never would have
happened if we weren't for this podcast
making these
you know these cartoons and i'm a little
scary because you know
sometimes you take on a lot of bur you
know when you take things into hollywood
it can get a little strange
um but hopefully we'll be able to just
end up making something that's
fun and and have an opportunity you know
we're trying our best so i do want to
let you know that
i also want to let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by
raycon and they have earbuds
you know there's a lot of i mean
everybody nowadays has uh
has something in their ears you're
listening you're enjoying this podcast
you know it could the old days you had a
seashell up to you
you could just hear the ocean or maybe
sometime you hear a fish
you know or an octopus do something
but now you need earbuds and raycon
has the pair for you whether you're
working from home or working
on your fitness you want what you're
listening to
what you're listening to to be what
you're listening to
everyone needs a great pair of wireless
earbuds
but before you go dropping hundreds of
dollars just throwing dollars at these
pairs
you need to check out the wireless
earbuds from
raycon they started about half the price
of any other premium wireless earbud on
the market i'm gonna let you know that
half the price think about giving a
bunch of money for something
now only think about giving half of that
money
that's reikon earbuds their newest model
the everyday
e25 they're the best ones yet
six hours of playing time
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass
and more compact design that gives you a
nice noise isolating fit
you know i don't like the the earbuds
that rattle them rattlers
i like them real tight ones maybe i like
them tied it up
unlike some of your wireless other
wireless options ray kind of earbuds are
stylish and
discreet snoop dogg listens with them
cardi b listens with them and they are
also
founders of the company melissa
etheridge brandy and j.r smith
and now's the time to get the latest and
greatest from raycon
get 15 off your order at buy raycon.com
theo that's b u y r a y
c o n dot com slash
t h e o for fifteen percent off raycon
wireless earbuds
by raycon dot com slash
theo go get them listeners
because you want to be able to hear
something
you know a long time ago i mean i don't
even know if hearing has always been
around
i mean i wonder what's up what's what
what
senses came first
you know that's a good question and i
don't even think the bible really gets
into that or even
i don't think uh you know
science which is basically just
you know kind of like an updated bible
kind of i don't even think they get into
that
you know what was the first sense
i wonder which one it was i wonder what
we need you know what
probably touch you got to have that
touch you know
you got to be able to touch something
man cup of tea you know
get a berry get a grapefruit
do something get some
you know i remember a couple years ago
uh
a friend of mine told me that he was you
know in love with man
and i had assumed i had i don't know if
i knew he i thought he probably might
have been
or either that or i just thought this
dude
never gonna get a woman acting the way
he does
you know because he's acting really
you know tender kind of soft-spoken in
the dick you feel me
like that and he told me he said hey man
i gotta tell you something
you know he said i'm gay you know and i
said damn
buddy you know and i said that in my
head i didn't know what to say outside
of me
i didn't know what what to use i just
i didn't know and i remember
like almost as a just a reflex i
remember taking
i remember taking my fingers and putting
them
in his mouth
or my mouth was it my mouth
i don't remember whose mouth it was man
i just remember
my fingers got kind of wet and i just
i didn't know what to do dude i just
i've never see you know
i've never been there on the front lines
of
you know kind of man you know
you know men only
kind of sexual communication
but anyway um
yeah what else man not you know just
getting through it
i'm getting through it
you know these cases keep going up
everywhere you know every time you turn
around somebody gets this and a new case
you know 40 000 people dying like what
way i just but maybe they are
and they always are blaming like a party
on the news you know they didn't say any
of the
remember that was a crazy thing they
didn't no one said oh the
you know at the protest people it's
happening at the protest it's fine
but just say the truth
that you know if hundreds of thousands
of people get together in the street
to share their voices then somebody
gonna get a disease man
that's that's easy you know i'm not even
good at math i'll tell you that
and but all the news is like oh some guy
had a party
you know some guy had a party outside of
salt outside of a
siesta key you know oh
people are getting at lance at a party
it's like you think
every you think everybody
got it from lance's party
no it happened with the protest man
which is fine i'm not blaming the
protest i'm not saying the protests are
wrong anything like that i'm just saying
why can't let's just why can't we just
have the facts
you know i think a lot of people can
live with the fact oh well people want
to do
you know express their freedom of speech
so you know in their right to
you know to you know
they wanted to express their voice and
people got the disease man
so but
what else man we got so we have some
cool calls that came
in we got you know we're getting through
another episode we had big tim dillon in
god that guy he
he's just like a turn back of the clock
if you listen to his podcast it reminds
me of a
of a rush limbaugh type of guy
he kind of takes you back to another
time let's play a little of this
[Music]
oh we already heard that one that
summertime forgets by midnight
let's hear this one summertime nights by
more than family
oh this is nice
you put the kids to bed you know or one
kid if you only have one
then you and the misses kind of snuggle
up
maybe an episode of 48 hours comes on
and you've had a couple beers baby see
you're hard you know that
or you're semi-hard which is the best
you can get
[Music]
and then both y'all you fall asleep on
the couch and your wife just goes to bed
without you
there you go that's it that's how it
works
we got some great video calls that came
in um
and you can submit those through the
website theovon.com
we have a great new website uh that you
should go check out
um let me uh get to one of those
uh right now here we go
oh hold on a little bit do a little bit
of this and that
hey yo theo i'm calling him from
virginia
uh i just want to start by saying i love
everything that you and your whole crew
do everything from this past weekend to
the fighter and the kid tiger belly
tiger pit i love all you guys
oh thank you and this is a young fella
this is a ginger gentleman right here
um and his name larry ritchie
go on brother but my question comes this
week from
uh the fact i grew up with grandparents
and they've always been behind the times
and i've
always felt like that wore off on me you
know and i started watching you guys
show at the beginning of the pandemic to
try and get an
idea of like you know like this is
what's normal you know
and uh but i still feel like i'm really
in the dark about everything so
um i guess my question for you is how do
someone stay informed
during these times you know uh
to everything that's really going on all
right stay safe out there
gang gang larry i appreciate that man
how do you stay informed and he had a
dog at the end there that felt
uncomfortable you could hear a little
bit of that let's go back and listen to
that dog
really going on all right stay safe out
there
gang gang and let's hear the dog one
more time uh
to everything that's really going on
so well first of all you got to listen
to that animal
if you got an animal in front of you
it's going through a tough time man you
need to do something
put your fingers in its mouth or put
your fingers in your mouth brother
uh thank you for calling larry and
sending this video how do you stay
informed i think you gotta just trust
your instincts
that's one thing that i think we're
getting back to
the news has jumped the shark the news
isn't even as reliable as the most
ignorant person you knew they have some
video and audio proof that's
it but i think a lot of it is just
trusting your instincts
and it's almost kind of nice that the
news has burnt itself out
you know it's almost kind of nice
because it's like oh okay here's
something else
here's something that i that i know i
don't need
i believe that if people if you're
really if you were making a point to get
that news all the time
we have to be careful that we're not
just getting it to fire us up
because i'm noticing for myself man last
week i got into it and
it fires me up
but it's not my fire
i'm that i'm transporting somebody
else's heat
you know i'm just i it's i'm not
and i think you know and also just
listening to yourself
check in with yourself focus on your
surroundings see what's going on you
know that's how you stay informed man
i think getting you know the the thing
we really need to listen to the most
right now is ourselves
you know i do believe that our hearts
will lead us into the best that
that's the best the best msnbc is right
in the middle of our chest man
listen to your heart remember that song
baby
listen to your heart
there's always that like big jack dude
that gets up at karaoke
and he's all he always will get but
listen to your heart
that's what i wanted to do listen to
your heart
and people are like damn this guy
is gonna be lonely for a long time baby
thank you larry richie
for hitting us with that beautiful
visual man he's sending a video man
um we had another we had a couple calls
that came in a lot of
you know we put a question on the last
episode
about if you had a if you had to take a
man on a date
and this is no homo type of stuff this
is straight up just
straight this is if you if you're a
straight man but you had to take a man
on a date how would you do it
what would you do we had a couple
answers that came in to the hotline 985
let's hear one game hey this is dusty
from leesburg again
what's up dusty and i've always valued
that type of name a name that also
you know kind of has an atmosphere to it
dusty stormy
you know windy oh there's windy you know
that [ __ ] will just scoot off in any
direction yeah
you know buzz i like that kind of name
oh buzz there's buzz
you know we've been hit by lightning and
you know him
you know bugs love him all right let's
hear it more of the episode and
you wanted to call in to tell you what
we where we'd take a guy on a date and
what we would do
and look i want to also now that i'm
hearing this back this sounds extremely
gay man which is fine if somebody's gay
that's fine
and if you want to be an adult gay male
then more power to you buddy i'll vote
for you okay
depending on what's going on and if
you're legitimate gang
i'm a straight man been married for
my wife don't hear this i don't know a
little while now dude your wife ain't
listening to this damn show man
gang brother but i like your attitude
man gang it's five six years somewhat
and uh i don't know where i would take
any man on a date but i pretend i'm just
taking me on a date
and in order to get to my heart you
would need to
okay take me to a
a nice state restaurant
buy me that porterhouse oh
dusty got that pricey tongue on him
onward dust
i need a medium with the outside chard
a little garlic butter on it maybe some
steak rolls if you got them
then after that all you need to do is uh
purchase me a bag of marijuana
and uh get me a couple of stick horse
rolling blizzies up with
damn dust so dusty's getting blunted
and that's the dude if you getting hit
hooked up in them giants dusty that's
that's risque man because that's risque
you know i remember when i was young
they had a
kind of a strand of weed that came
through town
and a lot of people if they smoked it
they was doing kind of gay activity
you know they'd shake somebody you know
you know i remember i know my buddy roy
smoked it and he shook somebody's hand
for almost a minute
you know where you'd see somebody doing
a piggyback for no reason
you know i remember a couple buddies of
mine smoked a bag of it for the funeral
and they doing piggybacks over there
right right next to the dead
and that's i mean that's
mildly you know that's damn 40
ga y baby you know
so it's just interesting when you think
about it
you know but that's i remember that
strand of wheat i don't remember what it
was called
but that's when that hit the scene
people
people were shook you know wives were
standing around in the yard just holding
their hand they didn't know what was
going on
because people was just puffing their
way right over on
each other's nuts you know and nutting
around on each other's bodies and that
kind of stuff
you know being gay um
and yeah sorry to have a lot of this
kind of talk on here but look this is
what the epis you know
we asked straight men if you were to
take a man
on a date how would you do it and i want
to tell you the number of calls that
came in
just blew my mind i mean we probably had
about 70 dates that got called in
um here we go right here and i think
getting it look man if you're gonna
that's brave of you dusty you trying to
get bent out
you know you're letting the man give you
that stake and then you try you let them
buy you a blunt
damn you a easy day dude damn
you an easy date bro you gotta tighten
up
man gang man onward let's hear a call
what's up theo vaughn love the podcast
man this is gavin calling from ritoso
new mexico the lower 48 baby you know
what i mean
amen brother praise god baby pg daddy
you know feliz christo
feliz christo papa yeah that's what i
grew up with
my name is gavin earl my parents are
white if you can't tell
but on your last podcast you wanted to
see what
you do if you take a dude on a date no
homo [ __ ]
well my question is what song plays in
your head when it getting [ __ ]
no homo mine's that lit from lint
biscuit
oh damn that song see it's funny i think
there should probably be like nothing
else matters from metallica or something
damn this this call took a wrong turn
bro you going
dude you just supposed to take the man
on a date buddy
gavin you know i respect you and
everything but you just there's nothing
that's wild man you're going real deep
bro we trying to keep it classy man a
lot of people on this co
on on you know a lot of us you know have
wives or hope to have a wife one day
you know a lot of us still chasing that
little
you know that body wallet bruh that
cooter
so that's too much for us man gang bro
be well
um what else man we'll take one more
one more call that came in man uh about
that
and uh and what people
what people thought was good here we go
this is adam from spartanburg south
carolina
what's up adam thank you for calling and
that's a biblical name
and that's a risky name too because
somebody died
who got killed at
the beginning of the bible
kane got killed he murdered his brother
so
you know keep tabs on your kiddos man
because that was adam's kids
so you got risky that's a damn brave
name dude adam
and uh but that's okay man you know that
could be part of the past man let's hear
more
i'll let you pause to do that what's up
adam thanks
um this is about that mandate
if you got a you know mandate for a
mandate
where would you go all straight no homo
gang bro if you down like that but
uh i think a perfect mandate would be
a little axe throwing you know what i
mean get that this athlete
hit her stand in line throw it out of
bull's eye
a tad bit you know romantic baby
a little scary a little uh a little fun
you know you ain't got a drink but maybe
whoever wants to get a little sip get a
little football
you know what i think step on with some
blades
sounds dangerous i like that man i think
that's a nice thing
you know i think that's a nice thing and
sometimes i envision a world where
things could be like that
where a straight man could take a gay
man out to throw some maxes or you know
hum some blades or whatever
or do bow and arrows or whatever or
shoot down a hot air balloon whatever
you know spend time together without it
being sexual or trying to be like that
but it's risky too a lot of gay men they
love that risk
you know it's i mean dude that's a
i mean that's risky
i mean that's wild bro but amen man i
appreciate you calling in and giving us
that option dude and just seeing what's
on seeing what's going on
we got one more that came in what's up
theo
uh i got my dog over here hacking on
some park
jerky this is joby from louisville
kentucky
and i was just answering your question
uh
if i were a man but i am and i was
taking another man out i'd probably take
her
him he she 20 20 i don't know that's
[ __ ] with me
probably take him down to the triple x
theater and uh
put on a good show and uh
watch some [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
because i'm not gay so how about that
there you go
[ __ ] you gang gang buzz buzz amen
brother now that's a way to do it
but you know that man is going to be
uncomfortable if you got a man at least
you know you know maybe draw some wiener
on a notepad or something to save it for
him do something
don't just think about yourself there
but also i think that could be fun
you know you take him out there and just
kind of you know have like a cra
you know for i think for a gay male
that's probably like going on a damn
roller coaster
taking him to a strip club you know let
him
you know hum a couple dollars at a
cooter
praise bro um
yeah a lot of great calls man a lot of
unique stuff but there were so many man
i just
you know i'd love to get in all of them
but it's impossible i can't even do it i
mean it's possible but
you know it's impossible more more so
i'm going to let you know though that uh
it has been reported
that americans which includes some of
you
are overpaying on car insurance by over
21 billion dollars
but searching for a better deal can take
hours and typically results
in a barrage of unwanted spam calls
that's true
don't you hate that you go looking for
the insurance and you type in online and
next thing you know they're calling you
you know deandra's calling you wilson is
calling you
you know elvira's calling everybody you
know
you know ignacio everybody's oh we got
the deal
we got the deal daddy but
that's changed now thanks to the
zebra.com
thezebra.com is the nation's leading car
insurance comparison site
because it's the only it's the only el
solamente place you can compare quotes
side by side from over 100 providers
and choose the best for you in 90
seconds or less that's right you get on
put the info bam within 90 seconds you
can make that choice
and they will never sell your
information to the spammers
uh so you won't get the unwanted bs
you won't get that naughtiness hitting
your line techcrunch calls
the zebra kayak for auto insurance
i use kayak actually for you know
flights and autos and that
i wish they had a train option only they
don't have a lot of they don't have
train options on there
but the best part is that it's
completely free that's right you can
save up to 670
a year using the zebra.com
to get the car insurance that's best for
you i would go and just check and make
sure
you know i did mine recently and i
realized that i was overpaying
and that if i went with this other
company for a year
that i would then get a 500 rebate so
that's nice
how much can you save on your car and
home insurance wow
they do in double go today and start
saving at thezebra.com
t-h-e-o that's the zebra
dot-com slash theo spelled
t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a
dot com slash t-h-e-o
go check it out see what they have you
know and see if they got something
special that you could use
up your insurance um
we got a call that came in here as a
video call
and uh and so i want to i want to keep
it man
here we go
[Music]
uh hey theo uh this is oz from
bethlehem pennsylvania uh amen brother
oz out of b uh bethlehem pa daddy
and oz is a you know it's a
[Music]
you know wizard of oz onward
and i just have a question for you
because
back uh in the winter uh
was when i man up when i'm in high
school and i
i really started smoking a lot of weed
with my friends and uh oh yeah
and that's fun as [ __ ] bro onward
you know it was a it was a beautiful
thing a little bit
just because we
you know we had such a good time we were
bonding you know
it was it was kind of our special thing
we would do
but oh yeah and i i think that strand
went around my town dude
because we would see you know a lot of
men doing some freaking red rover type
[ __ ]
you know adults onward
you know my mom told me the other day
that
you know it made her feel like she's not
as close to me
anymore since that happened back in the
day and that
you know that really kind of hurts to
hear that
that i maybe damaged my relationship
with my family because of that
and i i feel disappointed in myself and
like i let them down
so i just want to know if you have any
thoughts on how i can
help that but otherwise than that you
know
i just hope you have a really good day
man um
so thanks brother uh thanks
thanks for that oz man i appreciate that
and
uh thanks for the for the well wishes
there at the end
look you know
it's tough i think for moms when
when the children get high
because you raised something if you were
mom you raised something you've been
feeding us a little deal
you got a little duckling you've been
feeding them giving them milk
giving them teddy early and then giving
them regular milk refrigerator milk
you know you've been you know girthing
them up you've been teaching them
putting knowledge in front of them
giving the summer camp money
give them this give them that you know
give him a say you know give him
make a make a casserole for his ass do a
you know a party when he's 13 or
whatever all this [ __ ] they do it all
mothers and then imagine you've been
working on something forever imagine
even if you're a carpenter imagine
you've been working
you've been building a train you've been
building this little duckling or
whatever
you've been building a little you know a
little
uh a train let's say a train
let's don't pick different things let's
pick one thing you've been building a
train a little train
you working hard on it 14 years you've
been painting it and
and then suddenly you come home one day
you've been shopping or whatever
and the train is high as [ __ ] in the
middle of your house is driving around
it can't even shoot you it's so just
it's just back
you know it's it's [ __ ] shoving chips
and it's smoke stack it can't even
i mean that's gonna and you spent so
much time [ __ ] building that train
that's just gonna burn you brother
especially if you've been hitting them
big jaunts your mom might have not never
smoked giants
so she might be you know might be a
little jealousy
or jealousy baby um
but here here's here's what i found a
suggestion it would be this
i would just communicate with your mom
say look mom i i appreciate you letting
me know that that made you feel
like we were more apart you know because
that makes me
you know that makes me recognize that my
behaviors are going to have like a
that my behaviors could have an
emotional effect on you
and our relationship but just let her
i think if just by letting her know that
you recognize that
and i would also say you know i do want
to be able to be honest with you
um
[Music]
you know about things that i do imbibe
in or try or experiment
with you know i'd like to be able to
be honest with you you know even if some
of them you're not going to be proud of
me i want to at least be able to be
honest with you
so that you know
we can be building you know at least
we're going to
build a new type of trust because young
trust is different
you know your parents they they trust
you because
you know they need to trust you because
you got you know you're around the house
you could burn the house down and all
that kind of [ __ ]
but adult trust is a little bit more
different
you know it's a little bit of more of a
real
you know there's more of a commodity
because one of you guys doesn't have the
hierarchy over the other one
so i think man just the communication
will help
and i think just the simple fact you let
her know that you know
that it matters to you how she feels
that's probably the biggest thing
because she probably thinks you know she
might be a little soft
your mom might be no offense or anything
but she might be a little soft in the
heart
which is nice but it can also be kind of
hectic
when they say look you out there running
dope you out there huffing gas
and i'm at home [ __ ] you know
you know trying to do a strawberry
shortcake and now i feel like we don't
know each other
so but yeah dude sometimes you got to
get [ __ ] gassed up
i remember dude i found a joint
at home about six years ago that i
freaking hid on the top of the
refrigerator in college
so that shows you right there that the
[ __ ] cleaning lady
ain't doing her job at my mom's place
but gang bro
but be well man you're on the right path
and i said to say this wear your seat
belt no matter what you do
wear your seat belt and don't do an
eight ball bro
and don't even do a six ball dog
stay safe man you can do it bro cause
the big thing is you gotta stay alive
if you don't stay alive daddy
then it's nothing man
you know we all want young people to do
well
sometimes you see a young person you're
like damn i hope that little bastard
does well you know
i want to tell you guys right now about
a group
that i want to support and they are
called junior achievement
of southern california best known as j.a
socal
they're a non-profit that works
predominantly with low-income
k-12 public schools
lessons that aren't taught in schools
and may not be a priority at home
financial literacy entrepreneurship and
work
readiness those are some of the things
that junior achievement
goes into schools and does
forty percent of americans can't afford
a four hundred dollar emergency
fifty eight percent have less than a
thousand dollars in savings
seventy eight percent left live paycheck
to paycheck
ja junior achievement teaches kids
things like what a budget is
and why it's important they learn about
credit scores
taxes health care costs home buying car
buying etc
junior achievement has programs in
entrepreneurship
that is one of the first programs ever
students actually create and build a
real business with real
products just imagine if you go back in
time and you knew all these things
man it would be helpful well i want you
to check out
um a video at the end of today's episode
it's just showing you a little bit more
about ja socal
and there's going to be a button on the
youtube page today
uh for today's episode where you can
make a donation if you like
you know uh one of my best friends runs
this non-profit and
um and they do some really really great
work you know i've been fortunate to
work and do some stuff with him over the
years and um
and they just do some really great work
man when you go into communities where
where kids aren't even going to learn
this stuff at home because their parents
aren't doing it
you know and to get this to get this
information to get this intel to kids
it's really important you can check out
their organization at jasocal.org
but even better please consider donating
to this very awesome
charity by using the link button
on our youtube page
thank you guys so much um all right
let's get into maybe a couple more calls
i'm trying to think of what else is
going on with me
you know i'm a little nervous about
maybe moving i know people are moving
you know joe rogans has moved
um
[Music]
i'm a little nervous about it you know i
just think sometimes it would be nice
for me to have a little bit i've been
here for a long time
and there's nothing happening right now
you know i'm not missing anything these
stages aren't even open to perform
so sometimes it would just be like oh i
could just kind of take like a long
not vacation but just kind of feel what
life is like again
in a regular place in america
and um i feel like that could be really
really nice
i feel like that could really mean a lot
to me and it's kind of scary
you know to think about just doing
something new or not doing a new job or
anything like that but just you know
what living in a neighborhood i mean i
don't you know just just
having a change like that
um you know i would still keep my studio
here and come back for the studio come
back every couple of weeks
would be the plan um but
but yeah part of me is like oh maybe it
would make me real feel
you know adventurous get that adventure
in my body
because you know i would like to have
that
man what a smart kid you know the young
guy who's thinking about that kind of
stuff
being aware you know caring what your
mother thinks and feels
it's important and sometimes it's hard
to differentiate
you know sometimes it's we only see what
our mom thinks or what they say but
you know we don't think of what they
feel
you know we're also in a generation in a
time where people talk about their
feelings more especially on this podcast
this the you know the old slit your
wrist cast right here
um what else we got
what else came in today
a couple of good things a couple of bad
things anything wild let me see
hey theo this is jared uh i live in
nebraska
not from here but i live here i've been
listening to your podcast for
probably about a year now uh it's really
uplifting
it's helped me through a lot of crap i
recently quit drinking
that was about six months ago i just got
my six-month coin
oh man congratulations man you got that
six months that's brave you know and i
think
whether somebody has a drug alcohol
problem or they don't doing anything for
six months
man that's striking bro that's striking
you you you doing it daddy everything's
going better for me
got my daughter back in my life and uh i
just wanted to let you know that
your positivity really really shines
through and
it helps out people who
have a hard time kind of seeing the
light at the end of the tunnel
well thanks man you know you and you do
that too by just sharing your voice
right there
you know the fact that you got your
daughter back in your life you know
that's beautiful
you know you got you know and she's
gonna have a different experience man
you know there's no bigger experience
than having somebody that loves us
there really isn't bro no homo's dog but
you know what i'm saying there just
isn't there's no bigger experience than
having that
especially when somebody's little when
they just
you know when you just let them know
that they're loved so
you got to really let them know you got
to let them
know
you know look man you are [ __ ] loved
you got to shake their little
ass write it on their [ __ ] chest with
a damn marker
love you you know
[Music]
and you shake them and people so rattled
now we so rattled we can't even feel the
love sometimes man
but you got to get them when they're
young and i'm glad you can have that
option you're going to have that option
baby
you're going to have that option to get
the little lady and
make her feel loved man that's awesome
dog and congratulations man
speaking of nebraska uh what else we had
a call that came in actually a video
call
that came in about nebraska man um
and this will actually uh lead us out
man
let's hear this hey theo it's your boy
alex out here
lincoln neblastia and i noticed you're
playing evan bartles at the end of your
last uh
last podcast and i figured i'd share
share a funny story about that kid
i grew up with him uh we met in like
junior high or something and
during that time when we first met the
first time i met him he was we were at
this one act play competition
oh damn that [ __ ] sounds straight nerd
alert bro
one act play competition dog
no offense bro i'm proud of you but
still bro gang
a small town in nebraska and he was
playing the guitar over in the corner
and i heard him i was like damn this
kid's pretty good i was in the band
myself and i was musician for a while
and uh so i went over there and hung out
with him and then out of nowhere and we
were hanging out
and stuff and out of nowhere this kid
somewhere off in the distance throws a
[ __ ] oreo dead ass
hits him straight in the face oh yeah
and that's a damn that's a nebraska hate
crime but that's a midwest hate crime
somebody just beams a cookie at your ass
homeward in his guitar he gets hit in
the face picks that oreo up eats it
then keeps on playing brother and i
don't think he looked back after
after that point also his wrist clicks
real bad
when he uh when he plays guitar because
he fell off a long board
uh years ago so yeah just wanted to drop
a funny story about him it's awesome
he's getting the respect he deserves
well he's a talented man thanks for the
call
yeah man if you get hit by a cookie
that's life that's life in a nutshell
you know sometimes you get hit by
something good but it comes at you fast
it's dangerous it's risky you know might
be we
might be a you know an erotic man it
could be anything
you just gotta you gotta keep on playing
you know sometime life will you know
sometimes you drive them somewhere and
somebody [ __ ] hung a cinnabon at your
ass
what do you got to keep driving
somebody you know sometimes somebody
will [ __ ] you know
somebody will throw a starburst up in
the air and then just hit it with a
wiffle ball bat
and it hits you right in your bare fat
stomach and your stomach fat and your
body fat
and you got to keep on just living life
man keep on
jumping through the sprinkler
yeah so let's go out right here man we
got a great little uh
outro song right here and this is by
that man evan bartels
and he is um you know and
for the young fellow that called and
saying you know he's worried if he
endangered his mother's heart and you
know uh
you know this is the kind of song you
could tell her about
you know just the kind you know uh
you know just let people know what they
mean to you
and it's hard man i know it's hard man
it's so hard for me to
sometimes lean into the good stuff
you know it's so hard it's it's man it's
hard to commit to love isn't it it's
hard a lot of times man
it's hard to feel that you know
just in life sometimes it's hard to just
damn freaking to love mf
you know it's hard but you know
it can happen man you know but we got to
make it happen i know that
um i don't know what i'm talking about
if anybody needed that reminder let's
get into this song right here this is by
uh
evan bartels actually and if you've
never heard of this man
then i don't know where you've been but
this is a song of his that i really
enjoy
[Music]
you guys be good to yourselves man
you deserve it you know that and if you
don't man
then there's your reminder
[Music]
i could see the rain coming
from miles away
baptizing empty skylines
with the whole better days
then i tell myself this will all be
fine
[Music]
the way i am
every man that's walking will
fall from time to time
every time i feel the thunder
i remember i'm just a child
i would die
a thousand times
before i ever let
[Music]
and that's powerful you know
i just throw
and i tell myself
before i ever let you down
that's evan bartel's right there he can
do it
[Music]
oh
crucial battle
outside of a soup plantation
evan bartels maybe out of nebraska that
man i believe
[Music]
and he can do it
he can do it man that man he does it and
he does it well that's off his album
promised land evan bartels and you can
grab him and
we'll put a link in the informations
yeah yeah it's just important you know
it's important for us to you know we
just got to try to let people know we
care man it's important gang
you guys be good bro
[Music]
how is everyone
ja is that missing puzzle piece that
really
helps to complete our education the
classrooms are focused on test scores
they're focused on core curriculum
they're not focused on the business of
life the students learn about
being an entrepreneur business work
readiness
financial literacy to ensure that as our
kids come out of school
that they're prepared it takes a village
to raise a child and that's truly what's
happening here
i'm really taking my work-life
experience
and blessing someone else that volunteer
that woman
or that man who comes in gives me an
example
of a business person to whom i can point
and let the students know about
a world that can be theirs
it's opening their minds to the
possibilities of what they can do in the
future
when i grow up i want to be a teacher
when i grow up i want to be an
entrepreneur
i want to be a baker
a nurse i want to be a policeman when i
grow up
i want to be a coach i want to be a
teacher when i grow up
[Music]
a veterinarian or a doctor when i grow
up i want to be a lawyer
when i grow up i want to be an engineer
you are a great teacher you believe in
me
you give me opportunity you give me a
chance
you give me education you give me hope
thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you gracias
thank you
[Music]
you